he was a German creative director
fashion designer and artist he was
recognized for his signature white hair
black sunglasses fingerless gloves and
high detachable collars he was best
known as a creative director of the
French fashion house Chanel he's Karl
Lagerfeld and here's my take on his top
ten rules to success
enjoy all right let's kick it off with
rule number one believe the models have
upon approval Jeremy cheerin the Mon
enfant unbox it and trick to Folly self
difficile comedy machine the Mon
catalyst a treatise on mr. t password
exam a three equations record our model
chief rule number two strive to improve
I'm never pleased with myself I always
think I could do better
I couldn't make an effort I'm lazy I
mean it's ridiculous I know but I had
the healthy attitude and I don't think I
should change my state of mind because
when people start to think about their
past their art and all that that's very
dangerous
I do kind of apply to art don't be too
pretentious and the good thing is that I
get never liked the old holding stone so
and such any satisfaction of what I'm
doing I always think it could improve I
could do better and I could do more it's
ridiculous
but it's very healthy I say rule number
three don't complain I have no idea if
there's a secret of your or our success
I have problems formulating that but
maybe you're better than I am
there's no secret the only secret is
work well we'll get your act together
huh there are not so many secrets and
also perhaps a decent life don't drink
don't smoke don't take drugs or that
helps one survives better huh so I don't
think it's not yet company it depends
how much you want to do what you do if
you think your life whatever it is more
important than your work
then there may be problem but don't
complain don't think you're a victim of
the system I don't believe in that at
all
if somebody in this business is a victim
of the system that is he is not
integrated in the real job this would be
an another shopper it's the pressure is
too big
do something else rule number four be
free security relative only be the mom
sleep are opposed rackets jolt a little
bit on Twitter but Professor Koshiba
later but on econia see the middle of it
we measure puppy festively to compose
massima emotion with a scale a very fast
money decisive diamond point on them or
me what I should faint exclusively
ferredoxin tree a vaguely Vani a time to
Lee sounds - just read evil bastards
upon the person rule number 5 adjust to
change good brands I always think are
quite mysterious but yet today
everyone's talking every second but what
they're doing information became so easy
that we are over informed by things we
are not supposed to know we're not that
great to know but that is something but
never existed before so it is too
dangerous to say no it was better if it
wasn't better it was just different it's
up to us to adjust to our times the
times are not supposed to adjust to our
perhaps passage tastes so you have to be
careful you like it or you don't like it
the question is that the way is you can
do nothing against it that's an
evolution and evolution cannot be
stopped and will not be stopped tomorrow
morning I must be an opportunist I can
still live in my private world but I'm
not against the world of today because
if you are against it you are like
donkey shot I don't fight windmill
rule number six actively seek new ideas
I'm always looking for something I don't
ask questions I try to find answers that
sounds very pretentious so maybe I
shouldn't put it that way I really only
express myself in the form of
collections pictures and drawings
not in an abstract sentence ah but not
like someone who's got away with words
and can really say what it means one
mid-fall Kabuto begin Kellogg come upon
Vedanta punch more it comes to you in a
dream yeah yes it's not quite a
nightmare usually it dawn right before I
wake up but you can't just lie down and
say something will come to me you have
to make an effort sometimes that means
working for your wastebasket don't you
put about 90% of my work ends up in the
bin I don't save it some people have
archives but I don't do I only care
about what's next
you're never I did in the past is fine
but I don't hang on to it but you must
have it so clear that I think is need on
rule number seven create good products
do you think about what what will how
things will sell their performance when
you're when you're designing no no it
seems good not because then it becomes
marketing no I don't think about it but
I hope it will but I don't formulate
this no no no no no no I think that the
very unhealthy thing because when I say
or you say when I say - I'm a commercial
designer you know it's Carrie Donovan
used to say fashion is what people wear
mm-hmm and I think that is not changed
so I'm happy that so many people in the
world like Chanel and the other day the
owner of another big group asked me you
have permanent sales at sundered I said
why because the shops are so crowded all
that rule number eight don't wait for
inspiration my best ideas I have them
but I don't think about having ideas
that's very it's like electronic flash
is something like this suddenly gold
also do the daytime in the bathtub I
have sometimes the best ideas in the
bathtub
very strange oh yeah you cannot counter
you cannot see hope I will have my
electronic flashes no that's not that
sure you have to work at the same time
because when people say they wait for
inspiration you know I don't believe in
that you know inspiration is it's a nice
world but in fact you know the French
say the appetite come when you eat and
the ideas come when you work rule number
nine just do what you want in 89 90 I
think what we might have what might have
mattes we were in
a period of five or six sort of singular
women many fashion houses not attached
to big corporates was there a different
different sense of doing business a
different sense of marketing then versus
now or do you think marketing is about I
never used because I don't know what
that means no forget about it I don't
have to do that huh lucky you
yes exactly you know I think about what
I want to do but I think I found a good
solution I don't discuss it as marketing
people I do it and we'll number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
step is make every day perfect what is
your idea of a perfect day every day
should be posted up to you to work on it
and to make the day perfect say it's no
perfect day and if you nose would be
very sensing because they has only 24
hours and how will be the next day up to
you to make every day as perfect as
possible it's a question of will and
discipline now I've got a special bonus
tip from car on how to find your path
but I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
what does a perfect day look like for
you number two how can you just do more
of what you want and number three how
will you act today even if you're not
inspired to do so when fashion appeared
in your mind as a possibility for future
you know it's not as decision it was
more something I wanted I was always
interested in what people wear myself
included but you know it's it's sad you
don't know it's a world of fashion it's
something very far away especially in
those days it's not like today with all
the TV fashion was completely another
world something I don't know and the
stars of zillions of light-years away
from the world especially for my world
for my childhood for my in the country
but circumstances made it that it's
happened to
if you wanted to the top 10 I did on
Ralph Lauren check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and I said look I'd like to design
these ties because I think they could be
new he said the world isn't ready for
Ralph Lauren I learned to trust my own
sense